every day I help an animal walk
again I've now treated more than 25,000
different animals dogs cats sheep goat
llama and even a few
elephants good boy that feeling I get
when I see an animal Run for the first
time that smile on their face it fills
me with so much joy it's like nothing
else in the
world I feel brand new
come here Elsa come
[Music]
here
Elsa you know that right you love him so
much getting boots done again
well
all right
puppy Antonio is very proud of his boots
of
[Music]
course
okay good
job good girl
it's time to go to the
park Antonio and I we are currently
engaged I live in Florida and Antonio
just brought Elsa from
Brazil now she's going to have uh like a
completely new
life do you want to go on the
grass this is brand new to Elsa she has
a lot of space here come
on
Elsa Elsa right Elsa there you are
you're back you're back are you done
exercising you're
exhausted she's very limited she doesn't
last more than 10 minutes out and then
her boot starts to bother her and she's
she's also doesn't have I guess the the
muscles like other dogs would have all
right Elsa
ready
by
Elsa with the boots that she has now
they start to get loose after she walks
for a while oh There She Goes she's
taking them
off there it
is Elsa's uh Story begins in
2015 Elsa was rescued from the streets
in the poor area of Rio De Janeiro where
a lot of animals are
abandoned Elsa was in critical
condition she had a tick born disease
that was causing the blood to stop
flowing to her extremities her ears and
her paws that tissue just dies three of
her paws just fell off on their own then
this last paw she had to do the surgery
to fully amputated she was in such bad
shape
one of the nurses um in the animal
hospital he told us that she looked at
Elsa and said Elsa you know you're so
sick and do you want to rest or you want
to be here cuz if you want to be here if
you want to have a loving family we'll
do whatever we can just let me
know Elsa LIF up her head and looked at
her face and she took a
photo
I was on Facebook and then when we saw
that photo of Elsa I immediately
connected to her and I called the Animal
Hospital set up an appointment and when
we saw her we were
shocked she was in such bad shape it's
just so heartbreaking for us Antonio
stayed probably for 5 minutes and then
he had to
leave
I'll follow you he can
talk finally she was able to get out of
the animal hospital after four
[Music]
months
yeah she wants to do more but she just
can't by having the braces that will be
a game Cher for Elsa she'll be more
independent we think Derek will give her
a whole different life we would do
anything for
her I can't wait to meet Elsa but she's
going to be a really tough case and have
a lot of
challenges I'm going to have to make
prosthetics for all four legs which I've
only done just a few
times hello how's it going I am
inet very nice to meet
you hey man good to be here hey buddy my
name is CL nice to meet
you and this is Elsa huh a little
princess you're super cute
buddy yeah tell me a little bit about
Elsa yeah she was found in the streets
of Rio back in 2015 so it has been about
four four years and five months so how
old is she about five or six then yeah
probably five or six okay how is she
been getting around Antonio he developed
these beautiful boots love so how often
do you have to make and put on these
booties H every day in the morning twice
a day twice a day you're having do that
we've calculated about 5,000 boots way
jeez well you've done a great job as far
as the legs keeping those protected and
she seems super happy and really sweet
can I have her go on my lap and just
feel how sensitive she is come here our
girlfriend still always challenging
anytime you're putting four Prosthetics
on an animal which is super rare I mean
there's probably only you know 10
animals out there with four prosthetics
so it's not I'm not going to say it's
easy by any
means there's not a lot of skin or
muscle flap over the end of the stumps
so that makes things really difficult
left side's not too
tender so yeah the right one is tender I
mean she's pulling back just on the
slightest of touches this is the hardest
leg to build a prosthesis 4 by
far okay yeah doesn't like that one but
it's all four legs so we're got to work
together okay a lot of work ahead of us
there's a lot of work there is let me go
get my stuff out of my trailer and I'll
be right back in all right I've helped
about 25,000 animals in my career but
I've only done a handful of four leg
builds there are some cases I just
cannot fix there are definitely
limitations to animal Prosthetics and
this one's right the Border because
these are not your typical
amputations it was an infection and the
legs literally fell off so that's a huge
challenge for
me let's just get her comfy I think
that'll be
good it's a good
girl all right this one's
done good all right you can let
go there's your leg
back all right rear right so this is the
hardest leg by far the bone is kind of
protruding
it's very sensitive oh buddy so I think
I'm going to bend her leg like this and
that'll just be a nice surface to bear
weight through okay like
that sorry buddy be okay honey it's okay
I know this is going to be the one
that's hard you're doing good okay take
that one
off let's see how we did it Yay good job
that's the hard one so that's
good front
left last
one there we go yay good sometimes these
things take a couple tries especially
with a quad dog like this they're not
home runs right away every time I'm
going to do my best to make four
comfortable devices but it's really
going to be up to Elsa and her will to
run if she wants to do it that could
make all the difference in the world all
right guys that's basically all I need
right now it's going to be a long
process process in a short period of
time so I'm going to get started sound
good all right guys you
[Music]
girl these legs aren't easy to cast just
cuz they're so tiny but it's just going
to be one step at a time moving forward
through the process seeing how she does
with it and adjusting from
[Music]
there squeeze that in
there the molds have hardened and it's
time to strip them and start
modifying okay
good Elsa's legs look different as far
as the shapes and the ends of the stumps
two of them are surgically revised but
the other two they look more like a
traumatic amputation I don't want those
bones to cause her any problems so all
these unique little modifications for
each limb I think that's going to keep
her comfortable and hopefully she'll
accept them and take right to
[Music]
them
Elsa since the day we met Elsa we wanted
to give her everything we
just love her so
much it is the first time that Elsa is
in a different country is just a whole
new world for her so we're going to take
her to the pet
[Music]
gromer so this is Elsa this is Elsa hi
Elsa
you are just adorable we think that it's
important for Elsa to be at her bath
once she get the braces cuz it's going
to be her second
chance I think she would like H chicken
cheese cheese and bacon
Shada I think she would like all the
[Music]
the braces are very important we've been
thinking about them for a long time now
that she's here I'm super excited good
girl will definitely change her life and
our life because when we brought Alisa
home she didn't have her paws so we
don't know what it's like to have a dog
that will be
active she looks
amazing very clean right mhm was you
relaxing
Elsa oh
Elsa I know I know you did so good yeah
you did so well it's all good you're
getting your custom made bra tomorrow
that's so exciting I can't I can't wait
to see the new Elsa with the braces I
mean that's going to be the best that's
going to be the best thank you so much
we'll be saying a little prayer
thanks so I'm going to put some extra
padding on these guys so it's nice and
Squishy and cushy for Elsa's
[Music]
leg all right so I'd love to show you
guys the evolution of these so far this
turns into this can kind of see the nice
fit to everything
this is Elsa's sensitive leg and I'm
going to keep an open stump I'm not even
going to have any pressure on the stump
here cuz when I was just barely touching
the stump there she' draw it back I put
a lot of foam for weight bearing I hate
to see animals in pain it's just not
fair I think Elsa is extremely lucky
just to have found a family that takes
on this type of responsibility that
motivates me even more more than
anything I want to help Elsa just get
around go walk outside so it's a big
deal for
[Music]
me she's looking very
cozy this is a Bittersweet moment for
Antonio
today right now we're getting ready to
put the last boots on Elsa he loves
having that time with Elsa and I feel
that he's like okay she doesn't need me
like before but that bonding moment will
be different from now on it will be more
like taking her out and then playing
with her at the park be like just any
other
[Music]
dog your last boots
honey
J are you missing that moment
already yeah
definitely
you're
done people think that we were Angels
because we kind of rescued Elsa but she
is the
Angel she Ls up the room when you have
her around she just just full of love
she definitely gave us more than we gave
her good let's match these
up all right so we're done with the
build on Elsa all four legs uh I've only
had a few builds where I've made all
four prosthetics for all four legs on a
single animal this is another one of
those but this is the first time where
all four legs are designed differently
this is a really complicated case so I'm
hoping to see Elsa take just a few steps
today but getting a dog to accept four
devices immediately is a long shot a lot
of this is just going to come down to
Elsa's spirit and her will to run
someone's
coming come in hey guys hey hi you guys
ready yes are you guys are you you think
so are you ready all right guys May m
more maybe good good the negative oh
yeah what is that to the
positive here's one of her back
legs so kind of
[Music]
see you guys ready hi let's do it all
right okay okay let's go one at a time
good perfect everything's in
there and let's go we can go to the
front right one so this is kind of your
weird one the bent legs okay all
right yeah there you go Elsa these ones
in the front were hard because you said
she's can get out of things really
easily right so this angle will help and
then up here just so that she doesn't
rotate around her leg I made Little
Wings on there let's kind of flip you
manh handle you a little
more there you go
okay all right let's get this one you
can see how perfect the fit is with
these I just can't believe how nice they
are yeah what do you think huh all right
let's check this one this is going to be
a real snug fit for you
perfect her face is I know you're just
the easiest dog to work with
ever okay so they're all
on what do you think looks like a bionic
dog right does
huh so what do you guys want to do you
think I think you want to walk huh
goodbye all right guys let's go bring
her
outside very cool these rces will will
give her a chance to be healthier and
happier to feel free definitely she
smells so
good good
girl with these animals sometimes it
just takes a while for them to get
comfortable so even small steps today
will be a
victory you
ready she's going to go she's going to
[Applause]
go oh
man oh that was good that was
good ni let me do it
again
oh good job what do you think you feel
okay you going faster than you ever gone
before you want to go a little bit
more you want to go go get your
[Music]
M wow wa all right that you can't get up
with
her it's un
that's
awesome yay this is one of my favorite
fittings to date she's running I mean I
didn't think she was going to do that
it's really just beyond expectation you
don't get these moments very often and
I'm just so happy I got to do it today
with Elsa and her
family
man she's good
unbelievable she's very pretty with the
new braces I'm very happy all right go
go go go go
go now that she has those braces she's
free to go she's so confident I can't
believe how fast she's running this is
the freedom that we wanted for her for
so
long she just can't
stop
[Music]